hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm pleased to announce
that we're going to be going over one of
my own games today i'm going to be
giving commentary i'm actually going to
be doing more of these going to take
requests for different types of openings
different types of in games that you
guys want to see i'm starting to play a
lot more chess and so i have a lot of
games on file so if there's anything
specific you want me to go over in a
game just let me know and all i'll see
if i can put that in a video but since
we're going to be starting out today
with my my own videos we have a special
treat if you're not too familiar will
stuart - over at online chess lessons
he's got his own youtube channel
phenomenal player he's a national master
really one of the strongest players on
youtube and given some great chess
instruction he is actually going to be
commentating on this exact same game so
if you're curious you can not only watch
me give commentary on my own game but
you can also i'm going to have a link in
this video you can actually watch will
give commentary on my own game as well
so don't kind of give you two different
perspectives as far as both sides i'm
also going to have a link in the
description below for his channel if
you're not already subscribed I highly
recommend it there's a lot of great
stuff out there and I really want to
promote chess I want people to get
better at chess because I think it's a
beautiful sport so with that said we'll
go ahead and get into it and after you
watch this commentary make sure you
check out wills commentary as well in
this particular game I was playing white
my opponent we were playing on chess
calm I think he was in the high 1800s
maybe 1875 around there anyway I'll be
playing white and my opponent playing
black and I started with pawn to d4
Queen's opening he responded with Knight
f6
and then pawn C for the Queen's Gambit
and he decided to go to the Queens
gambit declined line with a six and then
after Knight to c3 development trying to
control the sunna board very very common
he plays pawn here to d5 now I'm just
going to continue with development first
bringing out my dark squared bishop here
and this is very important for me dark
square Bishop is always tough to get
involved when you're white obviously
very easy to go ahead and get the the
light square bishop involved into the
game you know a lot of times you're
bringing out this epon very quickly so
you never really have to worry about
this elector bishop but I do want to
play pawn to e3 looking to support this
pawn on d4 so before I kind of block out
this pawn structure it doesn't want to
make sure that I go ahead and get my
darks for Bishop involved into the game
and I'm also pinning down this knight to
the queen so nice little move for me now
he's going to play Bishop to e7 you know
getting ready to castle on the keen side
also trying to take away that pin right
here so really doesn't have to worry
about it I'm going to continue to
develop my pieces again no reason to get
too crazy if you've seen any of my other
videos I really talked about Center
controller board so you want to develop
your minor pieces control that center of
the board and then try to figure out
what your opponent is doing and then try
to come up with a game plan from there
so he decides to go ahead and bring his
Knight to d7 again getting his pieces
involved adding another defender on this
knight on f6 you know that's fine so I'm
going to go ahead and bring pawn to e3
again building up this pawn chain right
here and then getting ready to you know
bring my lights for Bishop involved into
the game and then really after I get the
Queen I have all my pieces developed I
can castle on the Queen side I can
castle on the King side more than likely
I'm going to castle on the King side
he'll just be a little bit safer there's
no reason he can kind of open up the
board a little easier on the Queen side
right now after he castles on the King
side so maybe a little too risky right
now to go ahead and castle on the Queen
side but those are some of the things
I'm thinking about as I'm playing this
he decides to go and castle on the King
side which which seems pretty logical I
go ahead and bring my bishop here to d3
now sometimes you may see other moves I
actually really like the the d3 move you
know if he decides to go ahead and bring
his pawn to c4 and I recapture here yes
I did move the bishop twice here but you
know if I look at it if I look at you
know this position right here and then I
come forward here I feel like I didn't
lose a tempo you know I almost feel like
I'm kind of you know in control the
center a little bit more I have both my
D pawn and my e pawn I have a really
solid structure right here he no longer
has his D pawn so you know while some
people will
recommend a different move I have a lot
of experience with just playing Bishop
to d3 so that that's kind of why I did
that and he does in fact take the pawn
here on c4 and I recapture with my
bishop now he plays pawn to a6 trying to
get some Queen side attack it as you can
see he's played pretty passive kind of
defensive right now kind of see where
I'm gonna move my pieces but he's
looking to to make a move he can't
really do much on the Kings side
obviously doesn't want to weaken his
defenses right now so you know he's
looking to you know maybe push
he's obviously you know he could have
you know an outpost right here he could
start to get his queen balled into the
game if he wants to bring you know his
pawn to c5 c6 so you know a6 kind of a
flexible move just still kind of waiting
you know you really can't do a whole lot
he can't get his Queen involved into the
game he can't get his bishop his rooks
aren't going anywhere so there's really
not a whole lot for him to do so I
decided to take this time to go ahead
and castle on the King side black now
plays pawn to b5 again you deciding he
wants to attack a little bit now I have
two options I can always bring the
bishop back here to b3 I could bring it
back here to d3
if this pawn was not here on e6 I
probably would have voted to go ahead
and bring it back here to b3 again I
want to kind of you know have a lot of
tension on this long diagonal putting a
lot of pressure on the f7 square that's
really a huge weakness but since he has
played this pawn to e6
you know the bishop back here on b3
isn't doing nearly as much as I'd like
it to so for that reason since he does
kind of have this fortified it's not as
weak anymore
I decided to go ahead and bring it back
to d3 if I can't have this long diagonal
I definitely want to make sure I'm still
having a lot of tension and your pieces
understand the board again are going to
control more space so I decided just to
kind of centralize this Bishop right
here now he brings his bishop here to b7
kind of like for white it's really hard
to get your dark script bishop involved
into the game for black it's going to be
your light square bishop so before he
couldn't move it anywhere so it
definitely wants to get this activated
because this is going to be his hardest
piece to activate and the last piece
that I
have to activate is my queen so I'll go
ahead and bring my queen to see - he
comes along and captures right here on
f3 a lot of people that you know Kevin
why did you move your queen here he was
kind of defending this Knight I have a
lot of experience in this particular
opening right here after I take my pawn
really what I'm looking to do again it
really depends on what my opponents
going to play but I would really want to
move my King here to h1 I want to get
both my rooks doubled up on this G file
and then once I can open this up again I
have my bishop here in d3 my queen here
on c2 aimed at this h7 square if I can
exchange some minor pieces off and I
just control this G file it's going to
be very very hard for black to hold on
so that's really at this point where I'm
going I actually really wanted to
exchange giving up this lights or this
lighter Bishop for my knight
the knight in this attack is not doing
as much so I was fine giving up this
exchange right here on f3 now black
decides to go ahead and play pawn to h6
of course you can see if I take right
here he now has a huge weakness here on
h7 giving up this pawn if I decide to
attack and he wants to this is kind of a
nuisance for him just kind of pinning
down this knight right here so I decided
to go ahead and exchange right here it's
not going to be do it's not going to a
whole lot of benefit just hanging out
here on h4 obviously coming back here to
the f4 is not going to do me a lot of
good so again I do want exchange some
pieces off because I want to kind of
open up the air so I can start to attack
so I go ahead and decide to exchange
here on f7 now once he recaptures with
his Knight I decide to go ahead and play
pawn to a4 and I'm looking to do a
couple things here but I do want to make
sure that he's not really counter
attacking too much on the Queen side
obviously I think I have a strong attack
coming up here on the King side but I
really have to be cautious of what my
opponent's going to do on the Queen side
so this is really just forwarding all of
his attacks that he's kind of throwing
out there if he decides you know to
bring his pawn down his other pawn down
I kind of have an outpost for my knight
or even my bishop would even be better
so it's kind of a flex we'll move and
just kind of kind of also want to see
what he's going to do next
now next move from black is pawn to c6
and this is a very important part into
the game because any time your opponent
moves you have to look at what was left
behind now this pond before was being
defended by this Queen here on d8 now
once it moved here to c6 you have to
look at this move and say what changed
in this scenario and if we look at it
this pawn is no longer defended so right
away I have a very aggressive mind when
I play chess so I'm always looking for
attacks any weakness I try to overload
that Square I'm going to really attack
my opponent so in this case I want to
attack this pawn right away so I'm going
to play Knight to e4 again centralizing
my knight getting him very active in the
board but I have a discovered attack
with my queen here on c2 attacking this
pawn on c6 so again always be looking at
where your opponent's are moving if they
ever leave you know a square or a piece
that was being defended and all of a
sudden it's not anymore
go ahead and attack that see if you can
overload it sometimes you know they
can't they can defend properly but
sometimes they don't even recognize that
you know have a discovered attack like
I'd be right here on the pond so instead
of defending this he decides to go ahead
and play his Knight to d5 which is great
and then I immediately come in and take
this pawn here on c6 now he's going to
bring his knight here to be for
attacking the Queen obviously I have to
move the Queen I obviously want to make
sure I'm also defending this Bishop here
on d3 and the pawn here on me too so I
go ahead and bring my Queen back here to
c3 now that the rooks going to come over
here to ca this is an open file now so
that this is definitely goodbye black he
wants to make sure that he has his rooks
on open files they definitely do much
better there because they can kind of
control more of the board than they
would let's say this rook here on f1 not
doing a whole heck of a lot right now
and that's okay I definitely want to
activate him later on
but rook the c8 you know good move so
I'm going to go ahead and move the Queen
back to d2 again I still want to make
sure that you know I'm protecting this
pawn on b2 and this Queen here on d3 now
black decides to go ahead and capture
here on a4 that's fine I'm just going to
recapture with my rook and then he's
going to bring his pawn down to 85 now
this is a good move um it's definitely
you know creating an outpost here for
this night the only problem is he does
have somewhat of a weakness with his
pawn he's you know right now this Queen
is tied up to this pawn so while he does
have an outpost he would obviously like
this outpost closer to my king but he's
definitely he needs to be cautious that
he's going to have to hold on to this so
from here I'm going to go ahead and play
pawn to f4 and this is a little move
that's wasting time a little bit I'll be
honest this is if we look at all the
moves in the entire game probably one of
my best move but just trying to get
myself a little bit of space I was I was
kind of looking at the board and
couldn't really figure out you know what
the next step should be I kind of if you
kind of looked at it but you know before
with my rook here on a5 on a4 I'm now up
upon a material more than anything I'm
trying to get to an end game there's no
reason to get crazy I can easily get to
an end game and win that I'm pretty
pretty comfortable in the in game and
openings that that's really where I
excel and so here you know I was no
longer thinking about getting my King to
h1 and then doubling up the rooks here
on the G file and then starting to
attack my Queen would have to come back
here to see to so I played pawn to f4
now black decided to go ahead and take
my bishop here on d3 and then after I
retake then his bishop comes down to be
4 this is actually a much better
position for black as you can tell not
only does he have a great outpost for
his Bishop here which is key but this
Bishop is also protecting the pawn here
on a5 so this is actually going to be
somewhat of a nuisance for me to deal
with because I don't really have a good
way to get rid of this I can move my
knight around it's going to take me a
couple moves if I'm going to kick it
around but
more than anything this is just going to
be annoying now from here I decided to
go ahead and bring my rook back to a
four it's not really doing you don't
want your rooks in the middle of the
board you know it came up to capture but
you always want to connect your rook so
I brought him back here to the first
rank here to go ahead and connect him
then he plays Queen to d5 he now
realized that he needs to play somewhat
aggressive he is down in material so if
he just kind of stays back and let me do
my thing I'm gonna run over the board so
he definitely wants to play a little
more aggressive what she's doing and so
I decided to go ahead and play rook to
c1 as we talked about before you always
want your rooks on an open file so
anytime I see a file the first thing I
think is how do I get my rook there you
also again want to connect them so I
feel pretty confident with my rook here
on a1 and here on c1 then he brings his
queen over to f5 and then I play rook to
c2 I'm gonna really look to double up
here bring my other rook here to c1
really dominate this file obviously he
has a rook right here so that's kind of
my gameplay now I plays rook over to d8
you know sure not not doing a whole heck
of a lot semi-open file but you know
he's attacking this pawn here on D force
that's fine so I go ahead and continue
with my plan bring my rook over to c1 I
didn't see anything that you know look
too suspicious so continue with that now
he brings his rook over to b8 he
realizes that this is not going to work
out well so he decides to go ahead and
bring it over now if he does move this
bishop he has a discovered attack on
this pawn on b2 I just had to go ahead
and play pawn to f3 now this is actually
an important move for me because I feel
like it it really protects this night
here on e4 I want to get this Queen
developed in the game and I know that if
I do that he can take this Knight right
away now I also don't want to move this
Knight because the Queen will just be
captured so I feel like this pawn right
here not only does it support this
Knight but I can also now swing my rook
over here to g2 start to put a lot of
pressure on this pawn on g7
really like this move f3 again it kind
of opens the door and kind of sees what
you know blacks going to do from here
the only thing I do have to worry about
is now my Kings a little bit exposed I
mean he was exposed before this pawn
here on f2 moves but so far I've kind of
dictated the pace of the game I've kind
of been in one attacking but the Kings
kind of open house I do have to look out
for that black decides to go ahead and
start pushing his pawn here to a4 and so
immediately I come Queen to a6 playing
his pawn to a4 yeah it's kind of a bad
move he had such a good thing going with
the pawn on e5 being a great outpost and
then all of a sudden right away he moves
it to a 4 and as we talked about always
look at you know what changed with the
move and what changed when I looked at
this is ok he no longer has this Bishop
defending this so I immediately want to
attack and I moved my queen here to a6
that was super aggressive I could have
always just brought my rook over to a1
but I I really like this double rook I
think it's so easy to play with so I
decided to go ahead and get my queen
involved into the game again very
important to note why this f3 move was
so important again it's holding down
this night here on e4 but if I didn't
have this this pawn obviously this Queen
on a6 couldn't come over here so very
important move the rooks going to come
over here to a8 I'm going to go ahead
and activate my Queen here to b7
obviously rooks and Queens on the
seventh rate can just destroy your
opponent I'm also attacking this Bishop
here on before so he's gonna have to
worry about that the work is now going
to come over to b8 again defending that
only this Bishop but attacking my queen
so I'm going to continue to attack I'm
always thinking how can I attack this
pawn here on a4 he's had to bring his
Queen over so it's going to be a little
bit tougher but now I decide to go ahead
and see if I can overload this pawn here
on a4 like now decides to go ahead and
come over here to rook 8a 8 he realizes
that I have double books here on a4 so
he needs an extra defender right here
I'm going to bring my King here to do
two if we're looking at all my moves and
we're being honest this is probably not
my best move I couldn't find a way to
overload this pond during the game
any more than I already had so I decided
you know okay that I really have no
strong pawn moves in my opinion so I
decided to go ahead and move my King
here to g2 now black responded and he
brought his rook down to a seventh and
then I guess he wants to bring his rook
back over here to a a triple load on a
four again I want him to have all his
pieces tied up to just protecting one
pawn while I try to maneuver and try to
attack him that's completely fine with
me I just had to go ahead and bring my
knight over here to c5 it's not really
doing a whole heck of a lot here on e4
so if I can exchange that or do
something else I would definitely like
that so he decides to go and take with
his bishop he no longer has his outpost
so his bishops just not as good and then
I decide to take with my queen again I'm
up in material I'm up a pawn I don't
really mind I'm not really looking for
trading off a queen but in this scenario
if he decides to go ahead and trade I
would be more than happy since I control
the C file to go ahead and exchange and
have my rook here on c5 now it would
kind of be a mistake if I took with
another piece you know I could take you
know with my rook right here on c5 you
know if I did that he could always come
down here to d2 and then let's say I
played King to d3 he could now bring his
queen to e3 this is this is kind of
tricky for me it's going to be really
hard for me to deal with this I you know
this pawn right here is now all alone I
have four pawn chains not really what I
want to deal with you know also instead
of the rook I could have taken with you
know could have just taken with the pawn
he could have easily now come down to d2
if you wanted to if I take he could
retake with his queen now if I come over
here to g3 you know he could take here
I'm b2 you know that's always an option
and then let's say I take here with you
know rook takes on a4 then he could come
tilt AE to putting a lot of pressure on
me I just really don't want to have to
deal with this I think this is a much
harder game
for me to win so instead I just decide
you know what I'll just take with my
queen if he decides to go ahead and
exchange that's fine with me it's going
to be much easier but I'm gonna have my
pawns intact I'm not gonna have to worry
about him coming down and putting me in
check and chasing me around the board so
that's why I chose Queen takes here on
c5 now he decides to go ahead and bring
his rook over to b8 and so I just had to
go ahead and bring my queen back to c4
again trying to overload this pawn here
on it for now he decides to bring his
pawn to g5 and I think this is probably
one of his better moves trying to find a
way to have some counter play right here
I really like my play if I bring root
over 2 G 1 that way if he takes I can go
ahead and move my king you know could be
2 f2 it could be back to H 1 it could be
2 H 3 and it would be a discovered
attack and I would still kind of hold
you know a lot of the momentum on my and
he'd still be you know responding to
what I'm doing instead during the game I
decided to go ahead and take with g5
which allowed him to take with his queen
on g5 and now he kind of has that
momentum back in his court he's now
attacking my king here on g2 and now he
kind of chased me around the board which
is kind of annoying now I still up in
material so I'm not feeling too bad
about the situation I don't see any way
easily that he's really going to get to
my king but it's again still going to be
somewhat annoying obviously I'm going to
move my king back so I'm just going to
move back to f2 he moves his King to h7
definitely he saw just me bringing my
rook over here to g1 winning that Queen
right here so he definitely wants to
make sure that his king is out of the
way and then I bring my pawn up to f4
right here attacking you know it's not
doing a whole lot but I really didn't
feel like it hurt my position that well
and then he brought his queen back over
here to h5 getting ready for an attack
and I decide to go ahead and bring my
King back here
to eat one now he brought his queen to
g6 attacking my rook here on c2 and I
just had to go ahead and take this
opportunity and take this pawn on a four
I probably could have taken this pawn
earlier you know when I moved you know
pawn - you know f4 could have already
taken it if I wanted to but I decided to
wait a couple moves and go ahead and
take it right here black now responds
with rook over here to b7 and then I
played pawn to b4 now in this particular
situation I was actually feeling really
good I think my position is fantastic I
don't see an easy way for him to come
around and attack me I have a passed
pawn here on the B file I think it's
going to be really hard for him to stop
that um so you know I figure he could
chase me around the board but all in all
I wasn't feeling too worried he just had
to go and bring his queen to g1
attacking after I move he takes so he
did get back one pawn in material but
he's still down upon a material he's
being attacked so he brings his queen
back here to g1 I bring my route back to
c1 chasing the Queen around he brings it
back here to g6 attacking you know again
he's just finding attacks that there's
nothing too crazy to commentate on this
part but I brew my king back here to eat
- and then he brings his queen to g2
bring it now back to d1 definitely want
to make sure that we don't draw here and
I just continue with the same moves over
and over and he plays h5 now I think
this is kind of a bad move I think it's
wasting time I do realize that he now
has a passed pawn as well so he wants to
start pushing that but in this scenario
he has a lot of the aggression and I
feel like this move wastes time and it
allows me to kind of get back in the
driver's seat so while I do think pawn
should be pushed as we'll see later in
this game I think in this particular
case you know it's it's not the right
time but I just had to go ahead and play
rook to c2 attacking the Queen he moves
back and now bringing the rook
or excuse me a king here t2 and I brings
his rook here to GA mess is important
because he definitely wants to make sure
that he gets more defenders
we're just his queen he's just kind of
being annoying chasing my King around
but he's not really going to do anything
so I decide to go ahead and bring my
rook back here to see one and then he
brings his rook down get the ball into
the action and screw my king back to d3
not too worried he's not really
threatening me in my opinion he's just
kind of again being annoying and he
plays Queen to f2 I you know I
personally would have liked you know the
Queen coming back here to h1 that's
funny brought it to f2 and I just had to
bring my queen down a see through now
best-case scenario is he decides to
trade off his pieces
any time you're up in material best
cases you can trade down because it just
kind of shows more and more how much
your head it's a lot easier to win you
know with one pawn in the King against
your opponent's king than it is you're
up a pawn but there's tons and tons of
pieces on the board and anything can
happen so you know he really should have
waited he could have played a lot of
different moves with his queen
thank goodness for me he decides to go
ahead and take so after we take right
here
now we have gotten to the endgame this
is where I feel most comfortable
obviously the openings I've memorized a
lot of openings I've studied the
openings a lot so I'm very familiar but
in game I really enjoy I think it's a
big puzzle everything's very precise
there's not a lot of ambiguity it's very
black and white precision how to do
something so I really enjoy that part of
chess so from here I know exactly what
I'm going to do I need to centralize my
King I have a passed pawn I need to get
my passport eats his past pawn and then
it's gg so from here blacks going to
play you know King here to g6 I'm gonna
do the same thing trying to centralize
and he decides to go ahead and play you
know pawn to h4 you know something like
King - you know f5 he's trying to block
me off I can always just play rook to a5
stopping him you know it's not really
going to do a whole heck of a lot just
him trying to stop me it's gonna be
super hard now he could have played you
know pawn to f5 that's not really
centralizing his King
but maybe would have been a little bit
better as far as stopping me getting it
to the center of the board I probably
just would have come around the back way
to kind of stop this pawn but he decided
to go ahead and start pushing his his
past pawn I first want to centralize my
king I can get to a lot of places if I
need to get to the Queen side if I need
to chase the king or if I need to come
over here and stop this pawn he decides
to continue pushing once I see this I
was okay I've got to stop this pawn or
I'm gonna lose the game so I come over
here to a8 you know I can slide over
here to h8 it's really going to be hard
for him to protect he can't really get
his you know rook down here to be won
and protected so I realized he's going
to have to do something he decides now
to play pawn to f5 I actually think this
kind of a bad move because this is
exactly what I want I now want my King
to come down and start to attack this
pawn here on h3 now he brings his rook
over to h7 which good idea but you know
it's kind of lost I bring my rook down
to a one you know bringing it over to H
it's not going to do anything but I
still need to make sure I stop this once
I stop this then I can March my own pond
up the board and then he plays you know
pawn to h2
good idea I'm just bringing my king here
to g2 then kind of the mistake in the
game he plays rook to h5 and and this is
a real question mark because all this
does is worse in his position he not
only yeah he's still defending this pawn
here on h2 but he's now completely left
this pawn right here undefended and he's
going to have to do a couple moves just
to get back where he was so while a lot
of times you want to keep tension and
just improve your position he just
completely wasted time so again as we
talked about before what our pawns
supposed to do pass pawns you push them
so I start to push up the board he now
realizes oh I got to do something to
stop him and then I just continue to
push pawns up the board
he now decides to bring his King ball
into the game I wasn't quite figuring
out what he was doing
first he tries to get it get there with
his rook and then halfway through he
decided to get there with his King
if you want to get there with this King
you should have come there a long time
ago instead of moving that you know rook
to H you know six or five wherever it
was shooting guys King volumes of the
game too little too late I decided to
keep pushing he brings his King over to
e7 I'm going to go ahead you always want
to put your rooks behind your passport
he now has to block it so once his rook
comes over again any time your opponent
moves you look at what did they leave
behind in this case he's left his pawn
so I went ahead and gobbled that up it's
now going to be pretty easy breezy he's
gonna bring his King over here I'm gonna
go ahead and activate my rook again
improving my position still holding on
this pawn after the King comes up I just
had to go ahead and take this pawn after
he recaptures the three pawns to one
there's not a whole lot blah can do
right here it's kind of a formality I
come down here to attack it he defends
it I get my King ball to the game
doesn't really matter he can't chase me
around too much I can just you know
zigzag at the board so he gets his King
I start to zigzag I now take the pawn
I'm now up three pawns so pretty easy
we'll just kind of go through these
moves you know it comes back attacks and
that is just kind of zigzag
I'm very methodical and then game I want
to make sure I don't give anything up to
my opponent so you can see if you run
this through some computer engine I'm
sure I missed some maiden seven or
maiden 17 or something all I was trying
to do is win the game so I'm going to
start to push my pawns obviously if I
can get a queen or something that's
going to make it a little easier so once
he brings his rook over I'm just going
to continue to push again now I can't do
anything
continue to push now all I need to do is
just move the King out of the board and
it's a free Queen for me so I'm going to
continue to push up the board slowly you
can't do anything he can't really stop
me continue to push continue to push
after he takes I get my rook and then he
has to move his king away and now I can
move my king in the next move I'm going
to promote get a queen and I'm going to
win the game so hopefully you guys enjoy
this video as always I try to make
you guys are actually learning something
so hopefully you guys can can watch
these videos and learn something from
watching me play also make sure that you
guys check out will Stewart's commentary
again the link is in this video
he also commentates the game as well so
hopefully since you have my perspective
in his perspective you'll get a better
idea of you know how this game was
played and some things that you can
maybe do to improve or what you can you
know take and actually implement your
game and again I'm going to be doing
more of these commentaries on my own
games so again if there's a specific
opening or technique or anything that
you want to see that you want me to
highlight a lot of stuff comes up and
all my chest game so I'll make sure to
to get that in future video so hopefully
you guys enjoyed the video and I'll see
y'all in the next one thanks for
watching